no no no no as soon as someone drops The
Virtue signaling I'm done I'm done it's
over all right it was a fun day you're
cool I mean what you did was weird I
forgive you it's fine virt singling
gross what are you talking about virt
that was the only one I was like
everyone's asking what is this what is
this what is this virtu signaling you're
talking about have you heard of that
before this is this is cancel culture
101 it's about power it's about control
everything's a trigger everything's a
responses has anyone got this guy's
number there's a lot of women that would
want to go out with it what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to like the video on your way in
and subscribe to the channel let's get
started guys being single and
overla the sun is in my face being
single and over those words are not
supposed to even go side by side my womb
would be screaming baby baby baby baby B
I need somebody to tear me apart we're
suffering and you know when you're like
you're not the type that like to H from
a man to a man you want like a
meaningful connection we're
suffering we are suffering check on out
your single friend with an active womb
we're suffering check on
us check on us we're suffering see you
know it's interesting what I noticed is
how she's talking about herself and
typically when women have a more
self-centered mindset that's when you
know they end up single and alone
because she saying check on me check on
me check on me check on us not what can
I do for them it's the same thing with
like an employee relationship like if
they're focused on what they can get
from the job rather than what they can
give you know typically those employees
last like short term ances are you have
been here before the chaos in the
markets oil and stocks just when you
thought it was safe and interest rates
were Rising new threats come out of
nowhere tensions are boiling from Asia
to Europe and adaptation is the key here
to safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you need some insurance Noble gold
Investments has been protecting
investors from disaster for years with
precious metals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven Safe
Haven shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3 o Silver America
virtue coin with its new IAS this month
if you open up your Noble gold
Investments IAS or 401K rollover you can
claim your coin today remember crisis
Cruise portfolios waiver and gold
insulate secure yourself against all
threats go to noblegold investments.com
now that's noblegold investments.com the
only gold company that I
trust women are so dramatic man there
was a dude in the comments that took the
words right out of of my mouth and they
said now imagine going through this
every day every second of the day and
that's all facts and unfortunately for
modern women they're going to have to
start doing this jumping from man to man
or continue with alone time because as
beautiful as they can get their attitude
can get much worse so it's going to be
hard for a man to make a connection with
you and take care of your needs because
most of these men out here now the good
ones anyways understand that modern
women aren't self-aware enough to even
think about theirs I wish you luck when
it comes to dating who has it harder
guys or girls I would honestly say guys
not to be a pick me but guys um they
usually don't get as many like as many
you know potential candidates than girls
but girls like we I don't know okay wait
the more I'm thinking about it the more
it's like okay girl girls we like have
it really bad out there but when it
comes to guys like they don't have as
many candidates yeah cuz women at least
have the choice between a good guy and a
bad guy we just tend to choose the bad
guys you know hence all the serial
killers that literally have female fan
clubs where men um typically just don't
have a lot of choice in general okay I'm
switching my answer it's going to be
girls because dang it she was so close
so close we literally get attacked so I
think what do you mean does this chick
look like she's ever been attacked in
her life really really or at least it's
perceived that way they can protect
themselves or fend off any potential
danger then the danger that happens
becomes a nonissue because there's no
report or anything that needs to be made
about it because the threat has been
neutralized so unfortunately men are
getting attacked out here even if you
wanted to say it was by a slight margin
because I think males were somewhere
around 75 76% in terms of being victims
of simple assault nonfatal assault while
women were somewhere around 70% now it
was the case that women were victims of
robbery more and also more likely to be
a victim of a partner or a spouse but on
the other hand you had men that were
more likely to be attacked by a stranger
and also Al more likely to be jumped so
as far as using the excuse that women
have it harder because they get attacked
well and I I think men if you included
all the like older women that pray on
young men I would argue that even the
grape stats would be closer I just think
men don't really say anything they're
more embarrassed about it or they just
don't view it like that statistically
speaking and maybe you have another
argument for that but statistically
that's just not true about something we
can do called a second date updates you
remember Amber um yeah yeah I I remember
great well she gave us a call and told
us that y'all had a great date but she
hasn't heard from you since and she
asked us to call you for her okay did
the date not go well no no I mean the
date was the date was going good um you
know I as far as the date I was totally
into her and the date and then you know
was weird like randomly her friend just
showed up on the date okay and then
well so this is weird so the friend
shows up and then dips off to the
bathroom her friend pulls out a folded
piece of paper with her phone number and
name on it and goes if this doesn't work
out give me a call what yeah exactly and
then she has and even if it does work
out give me a call
anyways what's up with that like she
just like oh
wow
Sensational scam it on you it was it was
like I some kind of test it was just so
contrived it was just like and on the
first date oh like to setup are you hold
on are you sure this was a setup and
maybe her friend wasn't just like coming
on to you and maybe going rogue a little
bit no this the way they had this
orchestrated was like they had practiced
it and they had practiced it poorly this
wom are so stupid out of a middle school
my god oh wow there's plenty of other
ways they could so obvious also like why
would the friend show up you know's like
oh I go to the bathroom right now yeah
and why would uh why would you invite a
friend on a
okay so here's the deal uh when Amber
called she didn't mention any of this to
us can we bring her in on this
conversation and see what she has to say
and see what really happened between her
and this friend and you and make it make
sense of course yeah Amber are you there
yeah okay so did you hear what Zach said
yeah so so okay it was a test but you
passed oh my gosh on a first date that
is insane ladies ladies we got to stop
being so crazy that is insane
wait wait wait hold on you're saying
this this really happened you were
testing him to see what he would what
like come on to your friend or go on a
date with your friend look we already
talked about this you know I mean I
mentioned that you know I have a baby
I'm on my own I can't introduce him to
my daughter until you know I know he's
like worthy so I figured I need to be
able to trust you oh my gosh a single
this is you know single mothers so many
men are willing to put up with another
man's kid which is ridiculous like so
many men will do it anyway I'm not even
going to like tell you that they won't
because there's always a man that will
but then you pull this crazy it's
like you guys try so hard to sell me
that not all the single mothers are bad
but then I just keep seeing evidence to
the contrary that you're all batshit
crazy sorry like just for us to be
together and then like probably around
my kid it's you know separate the week
from the chapter whatever all right that
was done I mean if you felt comfortable
doing that then that's okay I mean I I I
respect that that's that's your that's
your decision to do that for me I was
raised differently for my friend he he
he respectfully is saying you're crazy
acquaintances relationships Family
Trust is earned it's not a gimmick it's
not a test it's not a game you know it
doesn't like and think about this I mean
this is a whole lot of creativity to
figure out where this is going to be
down the line how much more crazier
these Test's going to get the deeper we
go the weirder it's going to be Am I
Wrong wow uh well if you've been burned
as much as I have you would no doubt do
something similar no doubt no I never
would I never would in a million years I
would never do that cuz if if two people
have something like if it's pure
chemistry if it's actually an organic
you know coming together of two people
that's one thing and maybe look 3 years
later down the line if things get weird
maybe you do a test then to figure out
if something's off yeah it's kind of
like he's not the one that burns you so
why should he have to put up with
exactly Kevin Samuels would talk about
this making the men of the future pay
for the mistakes of your past I'm a lost
cause go on without me save yourself so
many women it's like we make that
mistake where we make the next guy pay
for something he didn't even do
ridiculous antics you know that just
sounds you're talking very like virtue
signaling right now and you sound really
or maybe he's just like a better
character than you know gross don't
ghost me don't ghost me that's the thing
and don't put on this show you know what
are you like you've never ghosted
somebody can we get can we stop virtue
signaling that's actually what I would
like to say let's stop virtue signaling
ladies and pretend really chica you've
you've never ghosted anybody really no I
didn't do it or did I no I didn't or
maybe I did not do it did you I didn't
do it or I did who knows I don't no no
no no as soon as someone drops The
Virtue signaling I'm done I'm done it's
over all right it was a fun day you're
cool I mean what you did was weird I
forgive you it's fine virtue signaling
gross what are you talking about virt
that was the only one I was like
everyone's asking CH what is this what
is this what is this virtual signaling
you're talking about have you heard of
that before this is this is cancel
culture 101 it's about power it's about
control everything's a trigger
everything's a respon has anyone got
this guy's number of course we'll help
you out there's a lot of women that that
would want to go out with him
psychological warfare it's all game no
honey you're just trying to look high
and mighty when you're really a coward
no no no and first of all when you go
and you drop a honey that's that's
virtue signaling right there all right
if you're playing by your own rules and
then you drop a coward on top of that
now you sound like an elitist how do you
like that play a game this is how the
game goes he's destroying this bit
so we're going to jump in here because
to see if you guys wanted to go on a
second day now it doesn't sound like it
right no never no all right well Zach
thank you so much for coming on the air
with us we appreciate your time yeah was
sorry about all that but this is gross
hey who Amber obviously this is did not
work out how you wanted it to but
probably sounds like it's better this
way it's good it's good I would not want
to be with someone like that anyways
yeah they'll reject him even though I
mean she called the whole radio show
trying to figure out why she didn't get
a call back I learned so much well you
know fellas they keep on telling me that
what women do when they get rejected is
they put it internally well what do I
have to do to be accepted what did I do
wrong what is it about me but here you
have once again another prime example of
a woman a modern woman might I had
putting it on the man you're a coward
now you're trying to act like you're
high and mighty oh don't go there honey
but literally when a man does the same
thing oh I'm not your baby don't call me
dear don't call me sweetie the man was
nice he did something weird and he was
like M no now if I want to be fair and
objective I would say listen I really
enjoyed our date but that whole thing
that you did with your friend coming in
and coming on to me that was a little
bit over the top and for that reason I
don't think that we're compatible but
this is what I keep on saying modern
women get comfortable out here dealing
with bums and then they think when they
meet a guy that's actually stable he's
going to go for this type of stuff and I
keep telling you he's not money or no
money it doesn't matter if he has it if
the guy has good strong character and
integrity he's going to have been around
the block a few times and he's going to
see women have taken advantage of me in
these ways I've sat in the dark
analyzing these things in my mind before
I go to sleep when I wake up after every
single date and now I understand how
these women are moving what they're
doing is it frustrating you bet but now
I know to look for these signs and you
got caught with your hand in the cookie
jar you could have just said I want to
be up front with you I'm really enjoying
this date but I've been burned so many
times by what I thought was good guys so
do you mind if we take it slow I've got
a kid at the house and I want to make
sure that I'm doing everything
right I think our generation just
doesn't know how to communicate I I
think my I'm I'm at the end of
Millennials and I just think Millennials
ruined it for everything we got so w
yeah and this is some guys men are done
with this stuff they're not putting up
with it anymore this is why men are
walking away from marriage and
relationships cuz I mean this is pretty
crazy for a first date can you imagine
if you don't want to do that like they
said why don't you just go on more dates
and ask more questions to get to know
that person and you really use some
critical thought to think about where
that person is or what that person might
be like if you have a question figure
out because you're a woman figure out
how to use your language to ask it and
get an answer but of course this is
modern women at their height at their
Peak being modern women what else would
you expect and that's just my opinion
into the next video I'm out wow that was
so funny that was so funny
literally this woman and not not only
did she in invite her friend on the date
she also had the date
interrupt and hit on the guy wow that's
a lot of drama for a girl you just met
yeah guys you should not put up with
stuff like that this is craziness and
and the way he's thinking is correct if
she's coming with these problems now 10
years down the road it's going to be
even more crazy but let me know what you
guys think in the comments make sure you
like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next
time